hey guys Ryan right here and Dan Fabri
dear so Assassin's Creed I think this is
the 64th game they're doing actually is
128 128 Assassin's Creed videogame
mm-hmm
syndicate a lot of people are talking
about the cinematic trailer I've seen so
many different Assassin's Creed trailers
not the most familiar with the game but
getting a ps4 next month and I'm getting
a list of a lot of different Assassin's
Creed games I gotta play so I figured
out time I check out the syndicate
rather someone told me to I became what
it comes out yeah I mean I saw like uh
another trailer of this and it did look
good but let's see what III has to offer
us Oh III that means erection three
times the size close enough it's
anticipated to be rated mature now that
looks real oh it's very real yeah some
dudes about to get rekt
oh wait ss takes place in Japan a lot of
white people in Japan the London oh yeah
London Japan man he got a surprisingly
fast for falling down the stairs that
Jack the Ripper
with the gig the trouble of networks
come on hurry up fun never stops come on
look lively looks
the orphanage
are they gonna take the orphans
yes
Wow
all right good
the
oh no the horses
yes
save the orphans
why thank you for that
enjoy the pizza
who said is actually draw drink it would
go on touch to Nobu boss is thief of
children or you could do better
join me joy the rooks
yeah
okay mr. frog listen her we just fit the
money I mean just take a walk hate about
the money notes with me coming with a
rook come on soon enough
so you're like a recruiting game I love
it oh cool
forming an alliance huh
you know I gotta say I think this might
be the most interesting Assassin's Creed
at least main game because we watch that
smaller one the 2d platformer that are
the 2d one that looked really good this
seems like the most interesting one yet
yeah ma'am I'm really intrigued do you
think the lighter played as more than
just that one person yeah they also
released another trailer which
conference was it I think it was I want
to say it was the second which one it
was but they released another Assassin's
Creed syndicate trailer where they
showed off a female protagonist okay
that I believe you're gonna be able to
play as where he's more of a brute like
forts like knock down the door and like
Wrexham dude she's more of the sneak in
through everything and I'm gone cool
cool I like the whole London world that
we get to explore be a part of that
seems like it has the level of
authenticity and grittiness that i
really like yeah see you know people
have been a little let down by the
Assassin's Creed games as a way uh unity
unity was kind of a disaster day one
apparently was just bugged as hell and
it was it was a little rough go I just
feel like people are getting kind of
bored of it I mean they produce so many
like so many but I mean the thing is
this like they still consistently sell
it's not like rock band mm-hmm where
rock band they are in Guitar Hero like
they did they ran that [ __ ] into the
ground and to the point where is like
yeah rock bands basically the same
concept I do this notes get hit I get a
score and that hasn't changed but then
something like this is like you're able
to like alter and you can give a store
you can give more to it so that's why it
still sells there's a lot there history
to cover to that there's a lot of
there's a lot of history which means the
next one next one's gonna be like 1930s
World War 1 odd Germany I wanted to do
the 1990s that would be interesting with
89 yeah
let's go back a decade what's do the
1980s ooh then let's do the Age the 80s
instead of like a black hood you just
got this giant like neon green roof and
you get to place Kyle Reese that mean
you'll yeah just be the Terminator yeah
they should do anyway guys yeah thanks
for saying that was out if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out dance
gaming channel do it that cyber channel
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine do it because I want
more product placement
Robert McGill hey Ryan this is Robert
McGill from Brooklyn New York
but you can call me puffy Benjamin I
would appreciate if he gave me a shout
out I'm a huge Power Rangers DBZ
wrestling baseball basketball and TMNT
fan basically I'm a nerd oh well so tell
Alyssa that she should wear a tank top
with a short skirt because she is fine
with a capital F with that being said I
think he meant buck we're gonna do about
that damn hey see on your girl you
stupid you quit complimenting my girl
step complimenting my girl and her
fantastic looks an amazing personality
and talent I enjoy watching here in the
action videos and if you could tell the
rest the real rejects to follow me on
Twitter hey real rejects all of you
they're all in here right now all them
follow at puffy Benjamin it would mean a
lot to him he wants to see Alyssa in a
skirt and he wants to have sex with
Alyssa
ah well Robert McGill it sounds like
you're a horny nerd if I were to give
you some advice I would say choke the
chain as much as you can and also watch
porn so you can actually you know figure
out how it you can please a lady because
as a nerd I know you're probably not
going to get laid - you're like what
you're like 25 30 I mean you're you're
black which means you got more odds of
actually getting laid because you know
like black people have big penises it's
the way it works for all black people
and I found